jamais deux sans trois le comité
consultatif national sur l'immunisation
tranche en faveur d'une troisième dose
de vaccin pour tous les adultes par ARN
messager cette fois je pense que c'est
le bon moment maintenant avant les fêtes
avant que tu m'en rentre à l'intérieur
de lancer comme programme de vaccination
le comité recommande fortement en 50 ans
et plus d'opter en priorité pour la 3e
dose
avec l'avancée dans le temps de
les supprimer les travailleurs de
première ligne du secteur de la santé
les Premières nations et il nous et puis
tous les Canadiens danger adultes il
faudra néanmoins patienter au moins 6
mois entre la deuxième et la troisième
dose
si on doit le faire
de plusieurs facteurs je suis pas encore
sur la semaine prochaine nous étions
contre le reste
tu
vas rien au micro c'est certainement une
idée intéressante d'avoir des poux dans
encore une fois si vous êtes admissible
fait vous donnez votre dose de l'appel
rapidement
si confirmer l'achat d'un million et
demi de comprimés contre la covid-19 D
fabricant remorque et c'est traitement
par voie orale seront disponible dès que
santé Canada les auras trouvé ici
Jean-Philippe use Radio-Canada Montréal